This is the first piece of content I
ever made.
>> Don't let your
This is the first ad I ever made.
>> tired of fitness places that are
>> today, we make 450 pieces per week. I
broke the Guinness World Record for the
fastest selling non-fiction of all time,
106 million dollars in sales in a
weekend. We have a portfolio of
companies that did north of 250 million
dollars in aggregate revenue last year.
In this video, I want to show you just
how far anyone [music] can come and not
to judge your first chapter by someone
else's 25th or thousandth chapter. Also,
quick shout out to Dom Mazzetti, you're
the one who inspired me for making this.
Here's one promise I can make to you.
You will be cringe. And so, let's define
these terms real quick. Shame is
breaking someone else's rules. Guilt is
breaking your own rules. Cringe is
supposed second-hand embarrassment.
Someone saying, "Oh, that's cringe."
Saying, "I'm embarrassed for them." But
in reality, it's a defensive status
play, which means you should interpret
it as if someone says, "Oh, that's
cringe." They said that to you, it
means, "I'm beginning to change my
status relative to other people or
relative to them, and therefore, I'm on
the right path." And so, we have to ask
the question like, "Whose rules are we
breaking? Did we agree to their rules?
If we set the rules, what outcome do
those rules optimize for?" A rule is an
if-then statement. Is that true? How do
we know that? And why does that matter?
People seeing you try hard will say,
"Why are you taking this so seriously?
Why do you even care?" But the truth is,
they've never cared about anything in
their lives. Like, when's the last time
they took anything seriously? Of course,
never, and it shows. And so, I had a guy
once come up to me and tell me that he
saw how hard I was trying with content,
and then he said he almost outsourced
all of it down to Charles Week, and he
was and he was like, yeah, like bragging
about it. And I said, "Yeah, it shows."
He just like looked at me, and I was
like, "Yeah, it shows, right?" He was
trying to be cool about the fact that he
didn't try hard, but all it looked like
was that he was losing.
But back to point, is it cringe to care?
Yes, of course it's cringe. You can make
anything cringe by just caring about it.
And the only people who think caring
isn't cool are people in high school or
people who got older but never grew up.
So, be real about this for a second.
Just changing how I talk about something
can make it sound cringe. So, in the
fitness world where I came from, right?
Bodybuilding, you could be obsessed over
muscles, oiling up and posing in tiny
trunks on a stage for strangers. Right?
Maybe competitive chess, right? Staring
at a board for hours in dead silence,
obsessing over wooden pieces like your
life depends on it. Making YouTube
videos, cringe. Setting up light You're
going to set up your little lights and
talk to your little camera like an idiot
like no one's listening, right? Editing
for hours just for a couple views and
comments. Oh, writing a book, that's
cringe. Locking yourself away for months
or years, pouring your soul into words
that most people will never read. Like
you know just go sit away type on your
keyboard, right? Anyone can make
anything cringe, right? Because anyone
who cares about anything is cringe. But,
the worst and I think um Dom Mazzetti
said this and I love this. The cringiest
thing of all is to be scared about
looking cringe. So, why are you hating
on someone else who actually has a
passion or an interest or actually
tries? Like do we really want a world
where people care less? Because when you
make that claim like who do you really
hate? Who does the person who says
that's cringe really hate? Do you hate
them for committing to something or
yourself for lacking the guts to commit
to anything? I want to show this in the
the realest form I possibly could. I
went through the archives. I scrolled
all the way back and I um I'm a weirdo
about like I try to keep everything. So,
I have like my lifelong texts and videos
and and and and um and and pictures and
I'm very grateful for that. So, I'll
give you a tiny piece of advice to
anybody who's on the journey right now.
Document more. Like what I would say I
don't have any regrets in life, but one
of them is that I didn't document the
the struggle. I didn't document the
journey because I was ashamed of it. I
didn't want anyone to know. It's kind of
like the people who like when they're
overweight, they don't want to take
pictures of themselves cuz they're
ashamed. But, it's like one, you got to
face reality. And two, if you believe
that you're going to win, this will be
part of the story you tell. And so, you
like Kanye was documenting in the very
early days cuz he believed so hardcore
that he was going to win, right? And I'm
grateful cuz I knew the first the moment
that I actually started documenting
purposefully was the day that I had a
thousand dollars in my life in my bank
account after I lost everything. I was
like, I will never let this happen again
and this will be the beginning of my
comeback story. Hey guys, real quick,
many of you guys are getting started in
business and don't know but other
entrepreneurs have already tried to
help. And so, 3.6 million copies were
donated by other entrepreneurs in my
book launch and I'm donating these books
as well. And so, if you're starting in
business and you would like the ultimate
business backpack, all three books, this
one shows you how to figure out what to
sell, this shows you how to get people
to find out about it and this one shows
you how to make money from it. When you
have all three, you can actually get
started. All right, on top of that, you
have 30 days of school that you can get
absolutely free and all of this,
including the books, including school,
including shipping is 16 bucks. Yeah,
like we lose money on this. So, go grab
it. Um,
it's the ultimate thing I can give you,
my gift. Uh, enjoy. Um, if you go there
and it shut down, it's cuz we ran out
but as long as the link still works,
there's books. And so,
I want to show you some real stuff.
That's That's tough.
Um, but I hope you enjoy it because I
think everyone, you know, many people
will compare their current chapter to
like my chapter or somebody else's
chapter, whoever your your person is but
it's not real.
It's made up. Like Like compare it to
this. This is the first ad I ever made.
Now compare that to my first
professional ad that I ever made. It's
super cringe.
Okay, here's my cringey first post where
I was trying to get people to give me
money.
Right? I'm just like, "Hey, I started
this thing. Please, please give me
money." Right? Here is my first content
piece that I ever made.
Sounds very dialed, right? There's
strong hook, strong meat, strong payoff.
No, it's horrible, right? Back. And this
is the first YouTube video that I made
when I started making YouTube content.
And this is my first IG post.
Now, 90 days after that first ad that I
showed you, um
I lost everything for the second time.
And that's when I made my first podcast.
And so, my goal was to document the
lessons so that I had something to look
back to as I moved up in my career. And
I thought it'd be really cool if Buffett
or Bezos or Musk had done some sort of
like video diaries of the come up, the
top, right? As something that like an
artifact for us to learn from that we
could follow in their footsteps.
Unfortunately, the world is too rational
of a place to reward the undeserving.
That's a Charlie Munger quote. In order
to get what you want, you must deserve
what you want, which really means that
you've got to be good. And the only way
to get good is to be willing to be bad
for a very long time.
And so, this is my promise to you, is
that you will be cringe. These videos,
these pieces of content, your first
product, they will be cringe, but you
will also not be alone. And so, the
point is this, you'll figure it out as
long as you start, take feedback to get
better, and never stop. And if this
motivated you to stop judging yourself,
cuz hopefully these are super cringe. I
made an entire video on the iterative
process that I followed to get here,
which you can watch. See what this is.
Hey guys, and in your next installment
of the mind game series, uh I just want
to talk about love versus discipline.
And
it's a topic that I feel like gets
totally misconstrued within the fitness
industry because
Hey guys, welcome. Okay. So,
>> [laughter]
>> measuring yourself is a really important
thing in tracking progress so that you
can make adjustments to your meal plan.
Make sense?
You want to track as many variables as
you possibly can. The reason for that is
not because you want to see
>> What? Where was the recording button?
I don't know.
A trainer? Like I have no idea. Hi guys,
I'm Alex and I'm the owner of United
Fitness. So, welcome to our family.
Thank you for the opportunity to earn
your business.
So, I just want to tell you a little bit
more about what we do. Uh United
Fitness, we uh strive to be the leading
body in life transformation business out
there. Are you tired of fitness places
that don't make you have fun or give you
the results you want? Well, United
Fitness is ready to change that. And you
know how? We're going to have you
lifting weights.